but Peter also comes down to stamina  it's an exhausting format and I think  for this older generation that also  becomes a challenge yes definitely I  mean uh you I mean Chucky showed that he  can just play against anyone at any  given day but finally it turned out that  yeah 15 games in in four days this was  too much of a challenge he hit a lot of  steam definitely I mean he was so  energetic on on the first day and and  basically already yesterday he was kind  of suffering  yeah but he had a golden opportunity if  we would if he would have given this  Quincy to check King FC Queen B1 he  would have fined this then we will be  talking that wow Chucky is on fire yeah  it's uh always very tricky in this event  but let's move on uh Christopher